لقد كان تقدمًا مذهلاً
لطريق أوكرانيا للغزاة الروس وقد استعاد
6000 كيلومتر مربع.
يقول رئيس أوكرانيا إن هذه الأرض كانت تحت
سيطرة روسيا قبل أيام قليلة فقط ، وهي
الآن توفر حصادًا
غنيًا للجيش الأوكراني من المعدات الروسية المهجورة التي
يرسم عليها الرمز الروسي z.
البنادق الجاهزة لقتل
الروس ، استعادة isiam جائزة استراتيجية
تسارعت من خلال الضربات الدقيقة من
المدفعية الجديدة التي تبرع بها الحلفاء الغربيون ،
ومن الواضح أنها تعرضت لقطعة كبيرة جدًا
من المدفعية أو بضربة جوية ، يمكنك
أن ترى مدى أهمية
المدرسة السابقة بوضوح من الناحية الاستراتيجية
هناك نوع من
رسومات الأطفال على الحائط ، ولكنه يحتوي
أيضًا على
هذه الثقوب الكبيرة التي تم حفرها لتخزين
الدبابات أو ناقلات الجند المدرعة ، وحتى
قطع المدفعية ، هناك واحد
اثنان ثلاثة أربعة خمسة
تم عرضنا في مركز قيادة
في مخابئ مصنع قديم
لذلك رأينا هنا في الأسفل أن
هناك منشأة طبية
تسميها شيئًا من هذا القبيل
داخل هذا المخبأ
هناك
ثكنة ،
نعم ، كان كبار الضباط ينامون هنا في أسرة
مصنوعة من أبواب قديمة
، ثم بالطبع
مركز القيادة هنا
بينما أسير هنا ، إنه أمر
غير عادي تمامًا ، فهناك
تسميات مختلفة للأدوار المختلفة
لكبار الضباط الروس في هذه
المكاتب المدرسية التي تحتوي على  تم ترتيبه في هذا
المخبأ في
ما يشبه مصنعًا للطوب قديمًا الآن
أصبحوا بأمان هنا
تحت الأرض
لكنهم لم يشعروا بالأمان الكافي للبقاء
في إسرائيل ، والأمر المهم في النهاية
بالنسبة للقوات المسلحة الأوكرانية هو
التأكد من أن كبار ضباط
يبقى الجيش الروسي في حالة فرار إذا فعلوا ذلك
أن القوات المسلحة الروسية
ستنهار بالكامل في أوكرانيا
وربما تهدد طول عمر
أحد فلاديمير
بوتين احتفل هذان الزوجان
بالتحرير ، وأخبروني أن بعض
جيرانهم كانوا أقل
سعادة وأنهم ألقى باللوم على القوات الأوكرانية.
قصف منازلهم
لكنه أصر على أن القذائف القادمة
لم تصب أبدا نقاط التفتيش أو
قاعدة المدفعية الروسية.  ID
منزله ولذلك ألقى باللوم على الروس في
هجمات العلم الكاذب على المدنيين ، وقال إن
الروس تصرفوا مثل الخنازير وسرقوا
كل شيء من جميع المنازل الفارغة
قبل أن يهربوا.
المنتصرون الأوكرانيون هنا
كانت الغنائم غنية باستيلاء
إيسيام وطريق روسيا هنا
كسر حلقة رئيسية في سلسلة بوتين اللوجيستية
في معركة الشرق
الآن لديك
مشهد رائع لدبابة قادمة لجمع
مدفع هاوتزر روسي مهجور
[تصفيق
] سألته عما إذا كانت معركة صعبة أم
لا حقًا قال إن
النجاحات الأوكرانية الأخيرة قد لا
تكون بداية نهاية هذه الحرب
ولكن حتى الكرملين لا يستطيع أن ينكر أن
هذا الفصل كان قصة مؤسفة
جدًا لروسيا